THIS BED.
>> Tucker: TIME FOR A FINAL
EXAM.
WE PIT OUR FRIENDS HERE AGAINST
EACH OTHER.
AND FIND OUT WHO IS PAYING
ATTENTION TO THE NEWS.
AMY STOODARD AND GRIFF JENKINSES
AND BOTH HAVE WON BEFORE.
>> THAT INCREASES THE PRESSURE.
THERE SHE IS AMY.
>> I WON LAST YEAR.
>> IT IS BRILLIANT AND FOUND THE
SMARTEST WOMAN IN WASHINGTON.
>> YOU CAME BACK TO WIN.
>> Tucker: ADJUSTING THE
EXPECTATIONS.
RULES.
HAND ODZ BUZZERS AND FIRST ONE
TO BUZZ GETS ANSWER THE QUESTION
AND YOU MUST WAIT UNTIL I FINISH
THE QUESTION.
AND INCORRECT DETRACT FROM THE
TOTALS.
ARE YOU READY?
>> TRYING TO BE.
NQUESTION ONE.
ACCORDING TO THE NEW YORK POST.
AMERICA'S GREATEST NEWSPAPER.
WHICH HOLLYWOOD TRUMP HATER IS
DOING LEGAL QUESTIONS.
>>RO SANNE BAR.
>> ROSEANNE BAR.
>> ROSEANNE ODONLED AND AN
ILLICET CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTION.
AND EXCEEDING THE MAXIMUM
ALLOWED UNDER THE CAMPAIGN
FINANCE LAW.
AND ALL OF MY DONATIONS AND MY
GOAL IS TO SUPPORT ALL OF THOSE
OPPOSED TO TRUMP.
>> Tucker: HE'S TRYING TO LOSE.
>> YEAH, I KNOW.
I HAVE LOST CONTACT WITH THIS.
I AM GOING TO HAVE A PRACTICE
SESSION AT HOME.
>> IT IS LITTLE RUSTY.
>> HE WAS WRONG.
>> Tucker: GOOD POINT.
MULTIPLE CHOICE.
QUESTION TWOCHLT CALIFORNIA WAS
THE FIRST U.S.ITATE MAN DATE
THAT RESIDENT COMPOST OR RECYCLE
OR GO SOLAR.
>> C, GO SOLAR.
>> Tucker: TO THE TAPE WE GO.
2020, THE MAJOR ITS OF NEW HOMES
AND APARTMENTS BE BUILT
>> WHAT IS THE PROBLEM.
>> Tucker: DID YOU KNOW?
>> I DID.
>> Tucker: BUT SECOND TIME YOU
LOST.
>> THE HEAT OF HIS PALM WITH THE
BUSKER.
>> YOU ARE BACK TO 0- WROERY.
QUESTION THREE.
HERE IT IS.
WHICH RIDE SHARING COMPANY
UNVEILED PLANS FOR A FLYING
TAXI.
>> UBER.
>> Tucker: IS IT UBER.
>> UBER WILL PITCH HIS PLAN.
>> FINALLY.
>> THEY WILL USE HELICOPTER
STYLE ROTORS TO TAKE OFF AND
LAND.
>> Tucker: YOU MOVED IN THE LEAD
POSITION AND NO TRACE OF
EMOTION.
>> I WILL TAKE THE GINA HASPEL
FOR 5000.
>> Tucker: OTHER MULTIMEL.
GOOGLE UNVEIL WOULD A BRAND NEW
FETTURE IN WHICH A ROBOT
ASSISTANT WILL DO WHICH EVERY
DAY TASK SO THAT YOU DON'T HAVE
TO.
SHOP FOR YOUR FOOD OR MAKE YOUR
PHONE CALL OR C, DRIVE YOUR CAR.
>> MAKE YOUR PHONE CALLS.
>> Tucker: IS THAT CORRECT?
>> SEEMINGLY CREEPY ARTIFICIAL
RESERVATIONS.
CAN MAKE DINNER RESERVATIONS FOR
YOU.
>> Tucker: 1- 1 AND GO INTO
FIVE.
IT IS TIED.
AND THE OUTCOME OF THIS QUESTION
WILL DETERMINE.
>> OH, I AM LOOKING FOR
PRESSURE.
>> Tucker: THIS IS ACTUAL NEWS.
L.A. PD, POLICE CHIEF SAID
FAMOUS SUIT THAT ROBERT DOWNY
JUNIOR WAS STOLEN.
THE ESTIMATED WORTH IS $300,000.
WHAT IS THE SUIT.
LET ME REPEAT.
NOT THE LAWSUIT.
THE OUTFIT.
>> AS IT FABRIC.
>> Tucker: WHAT SUIT IS IT.
>> IT IS A MUTINY.
>> A SUPER HERO MOVE.
STSHGS FERRIS A BOWLY WERE.
>> IS THAT THE SUIT HE WORE.
IT IS A SUPER HERO FILM.
IT WAS IN THE SEQUEL.
>> I THINK WE NEED NEW
QUESTIONS.
>> THE ORIGINAL IRON MAN SUIT
THAT ROBERT DOWNY JUNIOR WORE
WAS STOLEN.
IF YOU SEE ANYBODY WHO LOOKS
LIKE IT.
>> Tucker: THE CORRECT ANSWER
WAS IRON MAN.
WILL HE TAKE FERRIS BUEL LERES.
MANY ROOTING FOR YOU.
BUT THE ONE ARM PHENOM WON ONCE
AGAIN.
>> I HAVE THE BETTER MUG ANYWAY.
>> Tucker: YOU LOST AND THIS IS
FOR YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: THAT'S IT.